john lester the starter is 2-0 this year
and four games pitched with a 2.74 era
tim anderson will step in for the white
sox
anderson running a five-game hitting
streak a homer in three of his last four
games
a roller to the shortstop baez
and two pitches and one away
left-handed starter for the white sox
dallas kykel three wins two losses and a
3.07 earned run average
ian hat
one of the cubs in the lineup that is
hitting of late 10 for his last 30
including a three home runs
and a swing and a miss strike three off
speed away for dallas kykel and he
strikes out in half
louise robert back in the lineup missed
a few games
rubber to drive
deep left field and it is gone
bring him home two nothing sucks
that was cannon fire
amanda's home run number six on the year
for
luis robert now 15 runs batted in on the
ring of brian goins
so ryan going is getting a start over at
third base joanne monkatta is available
tonight
and the 3-1 pitch on the way swung on
lifted the left in the twilight ian happ
locates the ball over near the left
field line he's there and makes the
catch
and that ends the inning wilson
contrasts the cubs cleanup pinner to
lead off this second inning
oh danny's on it and one down
another one of the hot hitters in the
lineup jose abreu now with two on and
nobody out two nothing white sox here in
the third
state up jose watson left center field
way back there at the wall
bring them all home three run home run
jose abreu and the sox have stormed out
to a five nothing lead
that's his sixth it's a three-run shot
and the white sox have taken a
five-nothing lead here in the third
jason hayward will try to crank up a
cubs rally against dallas kykel
to first the yell of cover we love in
empty ballparks and it's three to one on
the out wrigley field is where the game
is being played and the white sox have
themselves a 5-0 lead danny mendick will
lead off here in the fourth
the 1-0
that ball's hit well deep left field and
good again
oh a big plus sign for the sox danny
mendick adds one more it's six nothing
third home run of the game for the white
sox
and as mentioned second of the year for
danny mendick
six nothing white sox lead
and here is yasmani grandal
oh that ball's crushed
way out of here
way way out of here top row
thunder that's a two run homer for grand
all his second of the year
and the white sox have taken an eight to
nothing lead here in the top of the
fourth inning
eight to nothing white sox and the
batter is anthony rizzo
now the 0-1 showing bunt and pushing it
up the
third base side kaiko will field and
throw out rizzo he tried to bun his way
on through the shift and here's
contreras he lined out his first time
one-on-one caico 2 contreras
anybody need any firewood danny mendick
and they get contreras
so no runs the first cubs hit and one
man left after four innings white sox
eight and the cubs nothing that'll bring
up ryan goins who has flied the left
in every one of his at-bats so far
one and two on ryan goins
bouncer and a nice play by caratini and
they'll get the out at second
[Music]
remember victor is a converted infielder
before he became a catcher
and he made a nice play
base has loaded nobody out
here's nico horner there's a 2-2 pitch
and he got in on him once again with
that same pitch a high fly ball down the
right field side of his foul ground
it'll be caught there by jose abreu one
away javier bios coming up
here comes a 2-0 pitch
bouncing ball back up toward the middle
fielded at second base exactly by mendic
he'll tag the bag and throw to first in
time
and the cubs do not score dallas kykel
with some big time pitching here's the
gray u eight nothing white sox lead
he lines this one to left deep on the
run and making the catches iron on perez
anon perez is a very good fielder no
matter where he plays
two down nobody on seventh inning
eloy jimenez the batter and eloy hits
one of the air to deep left center field
that ball is ticketed for the bleachers
and it is gone almost as far as grand
all's
eloy jimenez
hits his ninth and the white sox now
lead nine to nothing
jimenez says you know it's not my fault
nobody's on where i can catch you in the
rbi's apartment to bray you but
i can definitely keep moving up on you
in the home runs
and the inning will continue
with luis robert colin ray pondering his
pitch and now the 2-2 swaying and a miss
strike three
and aaron perez the hitter
oh tim goes high to make the catch
that's why we showed you the basketball
footage just going to mention that
runners had to hold and it's up to nico
horner now the 01 to nico horner line
drive bases it to right the cubs finally
get on the board
coming in to score on the play is
caratini racing to third as almora
nico horner has a run scoring single and
now it's a nine to one ball game
well josh fegley is going to be the
batter with the bases loaded it's a nine
to one game now the one-two pitch
in the air
and a shallow right center coming over
as luis robert he'll make the catch and
the enemies come to an end
so nice job by dallas kykel there does
allow one run but strands the bases
loaded after eight white sox nine cubs
one and that'll bring up jose abreu it
is nine to one white sox
two and two
oh one more for the road
bring him home again
a two homer night for jose abreu
homer number seven for abreu
and now 23 runs batted in
and it's 10-1 white sox
so the white sox are going to take game
one it would certainly appear two down
nobody on victor caratini batting 10-1
sox lead 1-2 to perez swinging a miss
strike three at six wins in a row for
the white sox
they come into wrigley field and put on
a power display
and beat the cubs in game one of the
crosstown series 10 to one